[Musique]
avec l'interdiction d'ouvert leur
établissement au public depuis des mois
en raison de la crise sanitaire de plus
en plus de restaurants décident de
passer outre les mesures et d'ouvrir
discrètement leur table à des initiés en
france les restaurants clandestins se
multiplient bonjour ça va verser vocaux
il ya quelques jours c'est une brasserie
à paris qui étaient sommés de fermer ses
portes en raison d'habitués qui
prenaient leur repas à l'intérieur en
pleine journée
dans le même temps à beauvais de bar et
un restaurant connaissait le même destin
pour avoir ouvert leurs portes à des
clients et organiser des soirées
clandestines des événements qui se
répètent et qui ont même poussé bruno le
maire à mettre en garde ceux qui
braveraient c'est interdit ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles n'auront plus
de soutien de la part de l'état hier
soir sur le plateau de balance composent
deux camps s'affrontaient joseph
restaurateurs au bord du gouffre et qui
compte bien ouvrir
on est dans une détresse totale de
l'autre côté le chef étoilé yves
camdeborde qui lui contre cette
désobéissance si vous rouvrir le
restaurant il faut les mettre en danger
votre personnel et vos clients
je répare on dit en ce qui concerne les
français un récent sondage indiquerait
que 53 % d'entre eux affirment soutenir
les restaurateurs qui font le choix de
rouvrir leur établissement malgré
l'interdiction contre 43% qui
désapprouvent ses actions alors
comprenez vous les restaurants
clandestins comprenez vous les
restaurants kandestin non bah vous avez
dit oui là dans la foi vous non je
soutiens il faut que les restos ou sinon
c'est la mort des restaurants et en plus
ce qui m'énerve c'est qu'en plus de les
fermer
on fait tout pour que les restos et le
moins de chiffre d'affaires possible
avec le couvre-feu la vente à emporter
elle diminue fortement ils ont repas il
autorise pas les terrasses comme c'est
le cas à l'étranger
et là il ya un nouveau truc qui est
encore pire qu'au premier confinement de
mars qui était pourtant le plus triste
c'est que la livraison dans certaines
grandes villes est interdite après 21h30
donc imaginez le manque à gagner pour
les restants c'est terrible il faut que
les restaurants ou alors on avait appelé
la veille des restaurants au hasard en
demandant s'il était possible de
réserver pour déjeuner deux nous ont
répondu favorablement eurent accepté de
prendre une réservation la veille pour
déjeuner pour deux personnes sachez que
on a fait en sorte que ces resteront
soit pas du tout reconnaissable bien
entendu parce que on veut pas non plus
qui leur arrive des bricoles forcément
parce que voilà et les pauvres cc c'est
compliqué pour eux déjà et c'est vrai
qu'on peut comprendre
benjamin que ces restaurants ouvrent en
fait le vrai problème c'est que j'ai un
peut enquêter et en fait il ya trois cas
d'erreur est de 2,2 restoria ceux qui
ont qui arrive à très bien à vivre avec
l'aide c'est des petits restaurants
effectivement ils vont
mais l'europe ne sais pas si c'est le
cas il ya ceux qui sont des gros groupes
les grands restaurateurs comme les chefs
étoilés fait qu'ils vont la led à les
massifs ces 20% du chiffre d'affaires
ils sont il ya le chômage et d'excès
s'est allié à une grosse majorité des
restaurateurs qui ont des
investissements et toutes les aides
qu'on leur donne ne suffisent pas du
tout à survivre et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya mon ami un prêtre parce que il ya il
ya une vraie scission entre ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut ouvrir parce qu'ils
ont envie de rouvrir ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut pas mais généralement ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut pas ouvrir ce
sont ceux qui auraient largement aidé et
chef étoilé effectivement il ad beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres c'est
beaucoup plus facile il faut entendre ce
qu'ils sont dans une vraie détresse
nicolas pernikoff oui non je suis pas
totalement d'accord et le problème
qu'ils acceptaient les fardeaux fixe
pour la plupart des gens qui ont un fond
de commerce et qui ont des loyers à
payer puisqu'il ya beaucoup de bailleurs
qui n'ont pas accepté de reporter les
loyers donc c'est gorgé avec moi sur le
débat passionnant amérique des charges
monstrueuse ouais c'était juste pour
répondre à benjamin maintenant non je
suis pas d'accord parce que après il ya
cette liasse trilogie
on est dans un semi confinement depuis
des mois et des mois moi je continue à
défendre une chose c'est tout simplement
la civilité
par contre il faudrait qu'on passe dans
un confinement total beaucoup plus
courts c'est-à-dire un mois de
confinement comme on a connu en mars
c'est à dire trois mois mais mais mais
sec pour que derrière on puisse relancer
les restaurants et qu'on puisse tout
relancer là moi je suis très mal à
l'aise avec les restos clandestins parce
que là aussi c'est ce que disait hier le
le chef c'est à dire qu'on met en danger
qui vous mettez en danger vos clients
vous mettez en danger vos employés vous
mettez en danger tout le monde donc ça
sert à personne connue satine alors moi
ce que en fait moi je suis pour parce
que je trouve que le fait de tenir pour
combattre quelque chose c'est bien
beaucoup de personnes parlent d' égoïsme
alors qu'en fait c'est tout simplement
une question de survie
et d'ailleurs j'ai une question aussi
pourquoi tout est ouvert à dubaï par
exemple tu peux témoigner que tout est
ouvert à dubaï tous les restaurants
toutes les boîtes de nuit etc
il me respecte vraiment pas le port du
masque d'après ce que j'ai pu voir
d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre
alors pourquoi tout est ouvert à dubaï
tout est ouvert à monaco les restaurants
les boîtes de leveau l'opéra mais pas en
france
le modef gouy à monaco gilbert manacor
on peut pas soutenir des restos
clandestins c'est l'illégalité que vous
soutenez en disant ça je sais que c'est
difficilement les restaurateurs mais à
ce moment là la désobéissance civile va
s'instaurer et tous ceux qui restent
fermés ils vont être pénalisés par ce
qui ouvre donc c'est pas possible de
soutenir ça je voulais j'avais des
images mois aux caméras kabylie j'ai en
fait j'ai pas envie dès maintenant j'ai
peur que les gens
économie les red bull rond et voilà
c'est dit voilà donc on rit ils me
disent qu'on reconnaît pas du tout mais
bon vous savez j'ai qu'une confiance à
mr c est moi ce qui me gêne c'est que
j'ai fait comme benjamin je me suis
renseigné et j'ai dit à des amis comme
ça tient bien j'irai bien manger est ce
que vous mangez ce que vous sortez et
les gens m'ont dit mais gilles ya que
toi qui sors pas je nuance un dans un
petit milieu on mange dans des
restaurants parfois le week-end il ya
même des boîtes de nuit m'attendais à
paris qui sont ou encore messi mais on
m'a dit ça on m'a dit si tu veux sorte
que je dis moi jamais je dénonce en mer
mais c'est scandaleux cyril sahraouis et
magali hubert bien collectif qui s'est
monté à marseille et hier qui a été
soutenue par martine vassal donc les la
présidente du conseil départemental
ce collectif qui a été fondée par un
avocat qui s'appelle pierre bruneau qui
a défendu des restaurateurs justement
qui ont été placés en garde à vue par
rapport à ça ils disent que si un
protocole sanitaire validé par l'ia chu
méditerranée est suivi par les pompiers
de marseille
ça peut ça peut marcher il ya c'est quoi
le yak un restaurant qui vont
certainement réouvrir oui mais il ya
quinze restaurants qui vont y a quinze
restaurants qui vont certainement
réouvrir avec ce protocole sanitaire qui
est validée je vais vous dire je suis le
problème qu'on a c'est que si on n'ouvre
15 restons un fautif les ouvrir si c'est
ça le problème va ouvrir 15 restaurants
et les autres les pauvres propose à
marseille parce que si le test
fonctionne il pourrait à marseille donc
c'est une ineptie excusez moi alors
c'est à dire que et les autres les
autres ils peuvent pas rouvrir alors cet
été y avoir quatre restaurants c'est toi
ta chance dans mélange soit entièrement
macro rouge tout réouvrir pas exactement
si c'est exactement ce que je voulais
dire et puis le deuxième bercy jo c'est
que le fait de risquer de perdre ces
aides c'est ça vaut le coup d'y
réfléchir vraiment attentivement en plus
sur camdeborde
il n'était pas au début il a évolué mais
parce qu'il a eu une vie rude et donc de
combat il sévit mais non mais c'est vrai
qu'on risque de mettre vraiment en
danger dont il évolue et le swing le dit
hier soir dans ma lampe tempête va on va
voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
oui à 60 % oui ou pas et non à 40%